en faire un voyage commercial tu l'as
fait il voulait juste se retourner chez
chute chez ses parents donc on va en
2007 au mois de mars
mais en fait il a été il a été arrêté
juste parce qu'il était musulman c'est
bien sûr voilà quand il est arrivé chez
ses parents donc quand ils ont arrêté il
ya les policiers qui sont venus
l'arrêter emprise plusieurs mais sans
nombre ils ont arrêté alors il est dans
un camp où il subit là il était plutôt
qu'avec les et les chaînes ou mir qu'il
portait dont on sait qu ont ils subi des
brimades et humiliations
oui c'est surtout donc c'est pas tout de
suite au camp donc d'abord il était dans
un prison
donc pourquoi il est il montre les
chaînes tout sera donc il à rester avec
les chaînes comme ça attaché s'il
pouvait bouger juste maximum à 1 m 3
mois il faut bouger à la bougie cno m il
finissait pas bougé c'est la première
étape quand il se dévoile à ses
humiliations ces faits il frappe qui est
donc il était subi toutes les tortures
qu on peut dire et après ils l'ont
amenée votre part après ils ont commencé
après trois mois et dix jours qu'ils ont
commencé à faire de commandes de travaux
forcés voilà travaux forcés alors
apparaît que la phase ce qu'on a appris
ils font tout pour le dévier de sa foi
pour vous déviez de votre foi le
vendredi jour saint pour les musulmans
et pour force par exemple à manger du
porc pas seulement le vendredi c'est
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps ouais c'est cette ils font exprès
on peut dire comment qu'ils cassent le
moralité de morale de la personne
après quand il l'a déjà à tenir parce
que là ils pensent seulement pour vivre
la vivent il ya combien de personnes
dans ses comptes aujourd'hui il ya pour
le nombre il ya toujours une discussion
mais entre 3 et 5 millions personnes
entre trois et cinq millions de
musulmans dans ses camps dans ces camps
ils sont 12 millions au total
ils sont douze
il reste pendant combien de temps
lorsqu'on il a hélas resté huit mois et
moi qu'est ce qui se passe pour lui
là-bas c'est quoi le il les met où donc
voilà d'abord il était dans une une
pièce on peut dire donc il n'y a pas que
toi les terriens de taux donc comme je
dis qu'il aime même pas bougé donc il
est enchaîné
donc même si le petit besoin en oubliant
grand besoin c'est sur un petit bol ou
bassin qui que les autres comme on a
commandé personne qui peut ils ont déjà
un peu plus de temps qu'il est là bas
c'est lui qui servit à la manger tous à
temps le même truc dormir aussi dans le
même truc c'est pour ça maintenant il
sent pas les pieds il sent pas les coups
quand il ya plein de trucs qui sont ils
à celui voilà alors donc au bout de huit
mois c'est ça en novembre 2010 est il
est finalement libéré sans doute grâce à
l'intervention des autorités du
kazakhstan où vous résidez avant
l'arrestation personnellement c'est
plutôt c'est plus comme lui l'a raconté
le taux sert à les efforts que sa femme
qu'a fait d'accord sa femme c'est
tellement d'efforts qu'ils ont ils ont à
laquelle sa femme elle était au
kazakhstan dont elle est restée avec les
enfants tout ça et avec l'aide de mona
filiale dos nu donc pour la migration
tout ça donc voilà il a travaillé dedans
elle a fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
attendre son histoire pour que parce que
lui il était le moment il était déjà le
kazakh parce qu'il avait déjà recasée
voilà même pour ça même avec avec ça ils
nous ont arrêtés